[Musique]
Raphaël Jacob qui n'est pas arrivé
Michel c'est Auger bonsoir
entendre sur le chemin Roxane et nos
collègues de CBC selon leurs ressources
confirment ce serait bel et bien annoncé
demain pas éventuellement donc demain et
que en échange la fermeture du chemin
Roxane c'est-à-dire qu'on va refoulerait
les gens qui tenteraient d'entrer au
Canada par le chemin Roxane le Canada ce
sera engagé à accueillir 15000
demandeurs d'asile
par ailleurs dont des Haïtiens alors
Chantal première réaction manifestement
en tout cas la visite
a fait accélérer les choses que l'on
voyait
bouillir tranquillement depuis des
semaines des semaines et des semaines la
visite et d'autres pensent qui aident
probablement le président Biden a
participé à ce genre de noms c'est le
fait qu'on a commencé à draguer des
projecteurs sur les les réfugiés et
réguliers qui allaient dans l'autre sens
c'est à dire qu'il passait du Canada aux
États-Unis et ce qui permet au président
Biden de dire je règle le problème à la
frontière nord en clair
on va appliquer l'entente sur des tiers
pays sûr à l'ensemble de la frontière ce
qui veut dire dans le cas du chemin
Roxane que les gens qui voudraient
continuer à passer par là serait
refouler vers les Etats-Unis ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des gens qui
passeraient pas par ailleurs l'idée des
deux gouvernements mais surtout du
gouvernement canadien c'est que ce
chemin-là a pris tellement d'importance
que ça va décourager quand même beaucoup
de gens de s'essayer on verra l'usage et
oui en échange on rajoute 15 minutes de
place pour des réfugiés des migrants en
provenance de ce qu'on appelle du
continent nord et sud-américains donc
monsieur Biden peut dire et en plus j'ai
réglé le code de 15000 personnes qui
transitent par les États-Unis souvent ou
qui voudraient le faire et qui
maintenant pourront appliquer
directement pour s'en aller au Canada au
Canada Michel C
monsieur Trudeau c'est une
ça arrive au bon moment pour lui là
parce que le chemin Roxane on vient de
le voir avec notre collègue à Toronto
Niagara Falls dépression c'est devenu un
sujet pas que québécois là depuis
plusieurs semaines
à partir du moment où la question du
chemin Roxane c'est c'est canadienne
ça vous le dire que
il y a de ces réfugiés là qui se sont
retrouvés à Niagara par d'autres
ailleurs
des Maritimes avait dit on accueillir un
certain nombre mais quand même et ben là
il y a des gens qui ont enlevé la
belle-mère de Niagara France qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui disait bon mais les
autres arrivent je peux pas laisser ces
gens-là dans les hôtels donc il y a même
pression politique j'ai reçu de nouveaux
régler ça il y avait la pression que le
gouvernement logo mettait sur ses
épaules aussi et j'entendais monsieur
Biden se trouvait pour la première fois
avec les républicains qui essayaient de
politiser la question de la frontière
nord c'est pas une question de non c'est
une question plus de principe mais la
numéro 2 de la des républicains la
Chambre des Représentants madame
Stéphanie qui est la député de
placeboard
des représentants du Nord pour dire
qu'on a un grand danger sur la frontière
d'or alors pour Monsieur Biden la
couverture politique est là et pour le
contrôle au Canada je dirais on règle un
problème politique très clair
du côté du Québec et du Canada comme on
dit en chinois c'est un Raphaël Jacob
parce que Monsieur Bazin pourra dire GG
clarifié toute la situation de la
frontière nord ce Trudeau pourra dire
enfin on a réglé je vous ai entendu
finalement on a réglé le chemin Roxane
donc pour les deux pays c'est une
avancée là
mais je vous soumettrai que c'est
profondément asymétrique parce que d'un
point de vue politique même si Michel
entièrement raison que c'était ça
commençait à devenir un enjeu jusqu'à un
certain point aux États-Unis ça a
absolument rien à voir d'une perspective
américaine avec la fête la désastre
humanitaire et sécuritaire qu'on a à la
frontière sud celle avec le Mexique donc
je dirais que dans la liste des
priorités d'administration américaine la
question du c'était drôlement plus loin
que ça pouvait l'être du côté canadien
donc c'est d'abord avant tout je vous
dirais une victoire pour Monsieur
Trudeau d'un point de vue de politique
canadienne bien avant que ça soit pour
Monsieur Biden de point de vue
américaine une fois que ça s'est dit je
dirais qu'en plus du de la pression
naissante et croissante qu'on avait de
la part des républicains la chambre il y
avait aussi dans plusieurs médias
américains au début du mois de plus en
plus d'intérêt qui était porté à la
frontière nord la frontière avec le
Canada ce qui est soit dit en passant
assez rare ici donc encore une fois
c'était pas un dossier qui était pour
Monsieur Biden et socialement très très
haut sur la liste dans le contexte la
visite au Canada oui c'est important
surtout du point du Canadien et
évidemment il y a un peu de
d'impression dans tout ça dans la
question je vais vous poser mais est-ce
que on peut dire que la relativement la
relative bonne relation entre monsieur
Trudeau et Monsieur Biden a facilité
d'un genre de dossier là il y a des
ministres qui travaillent effectivement
depuis plusieurs semaines mais que
Monsieur byden oui ça peut l'arranger
mais admettons que ça arrange plus
monsieur Trudeau il a dit mais pourquoi
pas le Chantal ce qu'il n'y aurait pas
été le cas peut-être avec Monsieur Trump
Chantal si vous prenez Donald Trump
comme la mort les relations
fonctionnent n'importe quoi va toujours
mieux c'est vraiment pas une échelle
pour mesurer la relation entre Biden et
Justin Trudeau je pense qu'on devrait
attendre de voir l'ensemble ou pas des
annonces de demain parce que c'est pas
parce que Monsieur Biden a fait un
cadeau et c'est vrai politiquement que
le cadeau est meilleur pour Justin
Trudeau que pour lui qui va pas servir
sur d'autres tableaux
parce que d'autres
dossiers sur lesquels Haïti entre autres
la Maison Blanche est en demande les
dépenses en défense le temps la sécurité
de l'article donc il faudrait voir
l'ensemble du bilan de la pour savoir
combien d'activités ce cadeau là ou si
on l'a vraiment eu en cadeau ouais puis
il faut pas de cadeau de toute façon
même si ils s'aiment bien sûr mais
parlons-en tout de suite on va parler de
dogue après parlons-en tout de suite des
autres sujets qui seront abordés il y a
Haïti vous Chantal fait référence
Raphaël et Michel C aussi aux norades
défense de l'article on va vouloir
peut-être voir le rythme s'accélérer
Washington aimerait que le Canada
accélère le rythme il y a des questions
commerciales aussi on veut aussi entrer
dans cette révolution énergétique ne pas
être exclue d'investissement important
pour les batteries et tout ça Raphaël
donnez-moi les trois sujets les plus
importants selon vous de cette rencontre
de demain et d'une perçoit d'une
perspective américaine canadienne
américaine pour Monsieur Biden mais pour
nous je le souligne ça serait
certainement plus important
effectivement je pose la question parce
que là-dessus aussi sur la liste des
priorités c'est asymétrique d'un point
de vue américain lorsqu'on arrive avec
des demandes je pense que Chantal vient
de mettre le doigt là-dessus c'est
d'abord avant tout Haïti ça fait des
mois qu'en privé en public les
Américains poussent sur le Canada pour
en faire plus donc il y a ça d'abord
tout ce qui est défense effectivement
augmentation du budget quand vient la
défense je serai personnellement surpris
que Monsieur Biden écorche monsieur
Trudeau comme Monsieur Obama l'avait
fait en fait de mal Parlement canadien
en 2016 en disant que le temps se
porterait mieux ce Canada contribue
davantage dans un contexte de front
commun le relativement uni et solide
dans le dossier ukrainien depuis un an
je crois que Monsieur Biden va être
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus dans le
compliment que dans les et les reproches
par rapport à ça reste qu'on va
possiblement ne serait-ce qu'en privé
demander au Canada d'en faire un peu
plus ça serait je vous dirais numéro un
numéro deux et effectivement tout ce qui
est Norade protection de l'article à
quel point en même temps monsieur Biden
va vouloir aller sur la question
chinoise
compte tenu effectivement des enjeux
disons d'un point de vue de politique
intérieur pour Monsieur Trudeau
présentement ça c'est une question qui
est ouverte mais c'est très possible que
pour poser probable qu'en privé tout au
moins monsieur Biden en parle à ces
homologues Canadiens Michel c'est vos
trois items que vous jugez les plus
importants à surveiller
parce que les Américains disent il faut
moderniser
les systèmes de radar tous les systèmes
de défense aérienne etc sont un
moderniser du Canada pas mis son écho
depuis très longtemps là-dedans Haïti
c'est très clair que les Américains sont
en demande sur Haïti et la réponse du
Canada qui dit non on a des brigades
dans les pays de balles et puis on est
un petit peu à court là ça marche pas
américains qui disent non un gros
problème avec qui vous autres les
Canadiens vous connaissez ça vous parlez
français vous avez déjà lire une force
multinationale là-bas vous devriez y
aller alors ça il va y avoir une grosse
et du point de vue du Canada il y a
toute la question du protectionniste le
bail Americana qui célèbre sur 90e
anniversaire cette année c'est pas qu'on
n'est pas habituel d'avoir d'impact lui
mais ça couche toujours des problèmes
que vous avez dit le mot magique
batterie c'est toute cette filière là
qui peut être affectée par ça Chantal
je ferme la boucle en vous posant la
question vous qu'est-ce que vous
surveillez particulièrement de ce soir
parce que un dîner privé ce soir et
demain les réunions de travail si vous
me demandez ce que les milieux
économiques Canadiens surveillent ça va
être effectivement tout ce qui tourne
autour du bail American et la hauteur
aussi des des subventions offertes
offertes par les États-Unis pour attirer
ces industries là versus la capacité du
Canada d'essayer de faire concurrence à
ça je vous signale aussi en passant que
quand le président Obama est venu dire
ça Justin Trudeau venait d'arriver au
pouvoir donc en clair ça pouvait être lu
comme une critique du gouvernement
précédent je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'idée
qu'on se fait de cette visite c'est dans
la mesure du possible de projeter une
image d'unité et on va plutôt insister
là-dessus que sur des désaccords
Raphaël vous avez dit
vous ne croyez pas que on va en privé
sûrement bien sûr mais on va beaucoup
parler de la Chine
n'empêche difficile de faire abstraction
de ce sujet là l'influence chinoise
c'est un truc planétaire c'est pas juste
les Chinois se réveillent pas la nuit
pensait qu'au Canada mais il pense aussi
Michel seoget est-ce que ça on peut
avoir des surprises et déclarations des
des sur l'ingérence chinoise sur le
contrepoids des démocraties sur etc etc
si on en parle ce sera l'accord de deux
démocraties qui disent on risque d'avoir
des problèmes avec ça on ira pas dans le
précis dans le détail de ce qui est
arrivé avec le députés puisqu'il est
arrivé
avec les postes de police chinois
supposés un peu partout sur le
territoire canadiennes déclaration qui
dit il faut pas de gérance dans les
affaires des autres États parce que ils
voient ils voient les mêmes choses ils
pensent les mêmes choses les deux pays
sont très proches là-dessus il y a pas
de problème ok Raphaël tour de tablature
enfin très simplement monsieur Biden est
un allié politique naturel de Monsieur
Trudeau je crois que la dernière chose
qui va vouloir faire c'est embarrasser
juste intrudo surtout à la maison donc
ne serait-ce que pour ces raisons là où
cette raison principale là je serai
encore une fois surpris un petit peu
comme Michel Le qu'on aille vraiment
dans les détails en parlant de la Chine
et je crois qu'on va vouloir si on en
parle l'Allier de façon beaucoup plus
large à d'autres pays comme la Russie
bref à d'autres régimes autocratiques
auxquels sont opposées des alliés
démocratiques comme le Canada des
États-Unis
et l'ambassadeur au Canada de Joe Biden
ce message-là une entrevue et encore une
fois on répète les ambassadeurs sont pas
tenus de donner des entrevues sauf quand
ils ont un message à hybride le message
c'était je suis convaincu à
l'ambassadeur que le résultat des
élections canadiennes de 2021 pas été
affectés par l'ingérence chinoise et
c'est une préoccupation que nous avons
tous mais il n'y a pas dans son esprit
un problème canadien spécifique sur ce
front là bon un qui a un problème
spécifique c'est le député and donne qui
hier je vous fais entendre
21h35 je crois la Chambre des communes y
était dans un comité et apprend le
reportage de global
qui selon des sources de sécurité le
soupçonne d'être allé voir fait de
reconnecte et voir le consul général de
Chine à Toronto ce qui admet pas par
contre c'est la suite c'est pour faire
pression ou conseiller
aux Chinois pour des raisons qui nous
échappent vous allez m'expliquer tout à
l'heure ou pas conseillé qu'on retarde
c'est un retard de la libération des
deux otages Canadiens les deux mycours
pour ne pas aider
les conservateurs donc que le timing
n'était pas bon là je fais entendre le
député qu'on revient parler de cette
bizarre d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
en Ontario donc alors Chantal c'est
quand même étonnant
c'est étonnant c'est étonnant du point
de vue journalistique aussi d'ailleurs
je pense qu'on parle on devrait parler
d'allégation plutôt que de révélation
parce que quand on met en cause
quelqu'un de cette façon là à partir de
source anonyme contre lesquelles il peut
pas
acquis il peut pas donner la réplique et
qui sont entourés de Laura des services
de sécurité
si ça vous arrivez à vous que ce soit
vrai ou pas vous seriez relativement
sans défense et à cause de ça je pense
que la plupart des
politiciens sur la colline se sont
gardés quelque part une petite Jane
là-dessus ce serait pas la première fois
au Canada que les services de sécurité
laisserai aller des fuites pour dire des
choses qui sont fausses c'est ce qui est
arrivé exactement à ma mère alors pour
en nommer
donc
mais ça a un effet politique certains et
selon moi l'effet politique certains
c'est que ça rend de plus en plus
inévitable le lancement d'ici la fin du
printemps d'une enquête publique sur la
question exactement Michel c'est
exactement parce que j'ai eu ce matin je
dis qu'est-ce que c'est que ça mais que
ça soit vrai ou faux parce que pour que
ça soit vrai il faudrait qu'il y ait de
l'écoute électronique puis que les gens
globaux les vues le texte là mais je me
dis comment on peut être sûr bon mais
Michel mais ça rend inévitable une
enquête parce que là les gens ont dit
voilà et ça prouve que la Chine a des
députés qui peuvent avec qui peuvent
jouer comme des marionnettes
on est vraiment et les services de
sécurité qu'est-ce que vous voulez et
ils enquêtes puis ils entendent des
bavardages
puis là il rapporte ça parce que ça fait
partie de la façon dont on recueille du
renseignement la pratique c'est vrai et
ça c'est important de le dire l'autre
chose c'est que oui ça veut dire qu'il
va y avoir un enquête public c'était
impossible qui n'en est pas jeune
c'était impossible avant cette affaire
là mais là maintenant ça devient certain
parce que
la capacité du public canadien d'avoir
confiance dans l'institution
ultime qui est le système électoral
d'une Parlement et et comment s'est
affecté de façon sérieuse il y a pas
2000 façons de de régler ça comme on dit
aux États-Unis le soleil est le meilleur
des impactant on met ça en public c'est
comme ça qu'on règle un problème comme
celui-là
et il est déjà arrivé que les services
de sécurité de pays puis du Canada
Chantal parlait de mayera il y a
d'autres cas aussi envoient des rumeurs
aussi pour plaider un espèce de
sentiment d'urgence pour ensuite plaider
pour plus de sécurité ça c'est déjà vu
Chantal aussi la guerre la guerre en
Irak et les armes de destruction
massives dont on a qu'on a vendu à ton
nidlyer entre autres et qu'on a tenté de
vendre aux Nations Unies il y a une
historique là-dessus et pas seulement
dans des petits pays qui ont des
services de sécurité douteux les
services de sécurité ont des agendas qui
dépassent
ceux des gouvernements en place qui soit
conservateur libéral néo-démocrate et
c'est une bonne façon de dire à ceux qui
gouvernent voyez on a de l'influence
nous on sait comment vous tasser dans un
coin et encore une fois souvenez-vous de
l'insurrection appréhendée en octobre
sécurité
ce qui ne veut pas dire et en fait vous
dites exactement le contraire que qu'on
a pas besoin d'un câble public au
contraire là vous dit on a dépassé le
seuil au l'un des dépenses et ça serait
sain en démocratie qu'on qu'on libère le
plus d'informations possibles parce que
l'ingérence chinoise elle existe par
ailleurs personne remet ça en question
Raphaël premiers résultats
ah c'est fini Raphaël on se voit toute
la journée Chantal Michel aussi Michel
grand passionné de politique américaine
on vous serait avec moi à 12h30 demain
pour une spéciale on va suivre le
discours au Parlement de Monsieur Biden
conférence de presse et on va voir le
temps d'analyser tout ça merci à vous
trois bonne soirée à demain au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI